sense that he had a chance there big big
game and an even bigger game to conclude
the three-minute portion I'm on the
bullet is going to be one of the most
epic match segments I think we're ever
going to see it really will and you know
there's obviously it could be said about
any match you know there's a difference
between going in with the score tied or
one player has the lead but between
these two guys where you know there's
never really been uh that much of a
difference between them that one point
that one game a half a point makes all
the difference so yeah you could talk
about momentum but strictly based on the
score and how narrowly close these
matches have been yeah this game's
important you're totally right and this
is giving me shades of the Nakamura mvl
match where Hikaru was down by two going
to the final game of this portion and he
managed to win it and that really really
set the tono obviously he dominated all
across the bullet but if Magnus could
tie the matcher man would that go a long
way toward filling him with a lot of
momentum and right now this is
resembling last year's match where the
score going to the bullet I think was
something like a one or two-point lead
only for Hikaru we have a transformation
here in the R Lopez Hikaru has put his
Knight on E7 as opposed to F6 as has
been standard in their games thus
far yeah and also the trade on E5 I I
think the position last time we saw this
featured you know some rather strange
like Knight A5 uh B5 sorts of positions
Instead This one is much more calm all
around and I think Magnus is probably
happy here with a stable position that
he knows he could not be worse in
especially as the final game in this
segment it feels like a position where
if you want to draw to go to the bullet
uh you know Nakamura would certainly
acqu yes so uh you know magnus's game to
to play it looks like for sure and
hikaro has to decide on which side of
the board he's going to operate B5 is a
tempting move but you're also
introducing long-term weaknesses on the
queen Queen side as we know white will
have the typical A2 A4 strike you can go
on the other side and I think the move
huk car is turning over in his head is
actually G5 potentially even followed by
F5 but that also allows Avenues to be
opened up such as the queen dropping
back to B3 with a check I'm definitely
surprised at the move C6 that is ultra
committal and Ultra risky because look
at the D6 Pawn totally yeah th this
immediately makes me think of like the
direct approach Rook D1 uh the pawn is
loose and pinned so the queen has to S
side step but you know it introduces
options for white to play Queen B4
Bishop G3 E5 with the right amount of
pressure on the E7 Square this can turn
very dangerous and some really basic
moves that Magnus needs to play right
these aren't like you know out of these
world moves it's like Rook ad1 let's go
and I'm surprised he's not playing them
he's taking a large chunk of his time
here obviously he's figuring out the
right way to arrange his pieces but I
could just start with Rook D1 and Bishop
G G3 and then think he's played it he's
got so many easy ways to increase the
pressure on the pawn bishop G3 Queen B4
double Rooks on the defile he could do
all three of those successively instead
he expands first on the king side that's
such a typical Magnus move again playing
on both sides of the board it's been a
theme of this match it's a theme
featuring in all highle matches and
games yeah and this actually not only
maybe has the Ed of H5 in the future but
it really restricts black from that G5
idea G5 F5 no longer exists there's no
G5 Knight G6 and black could maybe try
to play for the E5 Square so the Knight
on E7 is restricted maybe it's going to
be reduced to Knight C8 which is purely
a defensive task toally and Knight C8
relinquishes the grip on the F5 score so
Magnus perfectly timing the move H5
hikaro doing everything possible to
avoid playing G5 and allowing that
Knight on F3 to sink its teeth into the
delicious F5 Square I think you have to
go G5 though uh by hook or by crook you
have to keep the F5 Square protected and
after white plays Knight D4 the problem
is that the Rook loses contact with the
D6 Square so black actually can return
to E7 with the Knight hikaro still
holding on yeah the Knight on C8 is like
it's actually the only thing uh keeping
him in the game because it's guarding
the D6 pawn and when the F5 square is
threatened it's guarding the F5 Square
so without that Knight on C8 big
problems in this position for Hikaru it
looks easy for Magnus to play oh
but he's offered maybe a trade and hi
Caro could have snagged that Knight off
the board now he doesn't have that
chance anymore he also could have tried
D5 but I think hearo is actually
comfortable with this Pawn structure
he's telling himself Magnus is burning a
lot of clock and he hasn't found a way
to win the D6 Pawn yet let's just kind
of keep the status quo and maybe Magnus
will over press I don't know if that's
the way to to to do it though because
like you want to play D5 but I think
you're going to need to recapture with a
pawn there
agreed and instead he's gone B5 sending
the Knight either back to E3 and again
we're going to see this Knight E7
classic but Knight A5 is also very
tempting attacking that new Target on C6
that's a more Magnus esque move I think
no he drops back to E3 okay I think
knight7 Rook D well yeah D2 D3 he goes
on a light Square just good good
practice there and after D5 he wants to
play Rook D1 and the pawns are going to
find themselves on fixed dark squares
for a potential end game maybe with just
dark Square Bishop
but D4 Hikaru slides his Pawn through B4
preventing C5 what a move obviously the
Knight is Untouchable there because the
Rook on D7 will hang and Magnus keeping
the status quo here with A3 he could
have taken A5 but I think he's trying to
surround the D Pawn with the move Knight
E3 to C2 which is a big Threat by the
way yeah and the the moves here that are
possible Knight D5 just to showcase the
pure Insanity of how many things are
hanging in that position F5 has a
similar idea Knight C2 there would have
picked off the D4 Pawn I think that was
a big Miss by Magnus he takes the pawn
on F5 instead but
hikaru's oh my gosh no there's Rook
takes G7 in the end and Bishop B5 Bishop
B2 but the king could sign step but you
could go to f8 I'm looking Pawn takes
Bishop D6 we're going to have to show
this after the game oraro might play the
move no the time is too low we have to
stay with the action now it doesn't
exist anymore that was an insane line on
we promise to show this after the game
no matter how the game finishes feels
like Magnus is in the driver seat he can
support the F Pawn with G4 that's very
scary remember Bishop D4 Rook d8 you
can't just rush and take that and that's
why Magnus bringing his King up to E2
supporting the Rooks playing for a win
the big trouble also on the clock he's
got 7 seconds and so many weaknesses to
defend
here yeah the king is going to be
improved maybe all the way over to
B3
BC just take it and take it oh he didn't
take walk into a permanent pin but he
doesn't want to do it but Bishop takes
and Bishop F6 there was easy Magnus
allowing Hikaru to get active again good
point Rook C B6 is coming though okay
now it's suddenly a three result game
again I mean Magnus could lose control
of this game and let that dwn
through o that I didn't expect that
looks like a good move Rook A5 it's not
hanging what a move Rook B6 maybe
surround the B pun and now a
trade check first it looks like keeping
both Rooks on the board was maybe more
dangerous uhoh King D3 oh the king comes
up rook B7 sending the king back and
Magnus has to find a way to infiltrate
hikaru's blockade oh Rook e two D3 oh my
gosh who has to be careful here it's oh
my goodness Rook F2 and he's going to
win the F3 pawn and I think hikaro might
hold this yep cuz if if the Rook could
get to E4 that would be different and
hikara holding the E file he cannot let
the king infiltrate E6 oh this is
incredible he's hanging on by an actual
threat and he's doing it incredibly well
he just goes rookie one rookie to I
don't think Magnus has an easy way to
make progress if you're
Carlson careful where you put your
pieces yeah Rook G4 was too risky though
I agree with hikaro stay on the eile and
that's your defensive method and I think
we're going to get a draw Magnus just
not finding a single way to posee
further problems I don't think such a
way exists he can't put anything on the
E file he car's too solid I think Rook
B4 is a reasonable try yeah bring the
Rook here so at least that's taken care
of but he does it in a moment when
Bishop E7 can be played Bishop D4 Rook
D1 pinning the bishop moving the king
back Magnus keeps finding newer and
newer ways to pose new problems but he
car believes The Rook end game is drawn
and it is especially with the King cut
off this way if the King was on D4
different why did he let he's got his
King to F6 and Magnus is going to win no
he's lost King G6 F6 it's over it's an
umbrella he's using the pawns as a
shield this is a loss oh my goodness how
many turnarounds F seven there was
winning on the spot as does
this and it's actually the presence of
the pawn that makes it a win because
otherwise black can play Rook takes F6
check and
stalemate and hikaro is annoyed he's
irritated and he has lost a critical
game allowing Magnus to tie the match
I'll give you the choice